so there I was just chillin slaughtering  me undead like a come through fiend when  they took my freaking cat and my sweet  ride to now it's time to make these  jokers pay out of my way [ __ ] I can  cat to rescue you know what in this game  I'm the [ __ ] hero and that cats not  gonna rescue himself and my rights to  keep that score multiplier maxed master  all my crazy weapons and blazed a path  to the top of the tax saving  leaderboards you definitely want in on  this action it's chock full of awesome  enemies sick combos and have challenged  us in all you hardcore types crying home  to mama just look at these guys whose  butts I get to kick they keep trying to  punch me and that me and she peed burned  me and stalk me cut me and blow me apart  what one more all right guys rule the  montage  family